[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
avec un saut vers chargé puisque on va
parler de jacques chirac on va parler de
jeff koons on va parler de liberté
d'expression de rouen de ce qui s'est
passé à la préfecture de police d
assassiner à la préfecture de police et
pour en parler
lionel levy bonjour journalistes et vous
êtes membre du collectif intra muros
extra muros ah oui c'est lui salut
journalistes ce qui si elle reste dans
son bureau c'est pas de faire et vous
êtes le collaborateur régulier du canard
enchaîné jean baptiste duclair bonjour
bonjour patrice ça va bien ça va très
bien alors l'université ouvre ses portes
donc en plein boulot que vous enseignez
l'université versailles saint quentin
exactement de conférence rajoelina a
signé toujours harcourt d'ailleurs vous
avez senti les odeurs connaissent pas et
vous en seriez aussi à sciences po
en effet et jean charles lajoie dit
bonjour toujours et dit toujours et on
va peut-être en fin d'émission on
comparera de jackpot de ceux des
familles c'est un chef-d'oeuvre est un
chef-d'oeuvre c'est d'avoir la session
aura iconoclaste et politiquement très
incorrect et les ja vous n'êtes pas venu
les mains vides et il ya aussi des neuf
jours du cafard excellent polar plus
perçue par les sifflets l'ancien
chroniqueur hippique à vous ben voilà
c'est ça que ça se passe pas dans des
shows qui cite ici si ce n'est pas lui
le ba ba ça se passe à deauville en fait
d'accord entre deauville et l'angleterre
on en reparlera peut-être avec plaisir
alors on va commencer par l'événement
l'événement c'est ce qui s'est passé à
la préfecture de police est l'événement
[Musique]
alors les vêtements c'est évidemment ce
qui s'est passé jeudi à la préfecture de
police de paris
l'assassinât de quatre fonctionnaires de
police par un membre de la préfecture de
police alors avec évidemment cette
question à ce que c'est un acte de folie
est ce que c'est un acte de terrorisme
moi personnellement je trouve qu'on en
fait beaucoup mais qui sait peut-être
pas votre votre opinion jean charles par
exemple moi je suis assez étonné l'a
d'abord se rassurer pour les
sourds-muets puisqu'au d'abord on nous
l'a présenté comme un sourd muet donc je
suis sourd muet vont être ostracisé ce
type on estime baptisé donc là
maintenant on est rassuré pour les
sourds-muets puisqu'il s'est radicalisée
donc après dans l'état des informations
qu'on verra les qualités vie n'est
peut-être pas on a l'air de dire enfin
en tout cas c'est un peu un peu curieux
et quand on parle de coup de folie je me
dis c'est une folie qui s'étend sur un
coup de folie long parce qu'il faut
quand même qu'il a et qui il a pris son
couteau de cuisine il rentra préfecture
de police dans lequel a priori on peut
pas rentrer n'ont plus qu'un couteau de
cuisine comme si on était chez soi et
puis après tué quatre personnes qui sont
plus pas des vieillards qui sont des
policiers qui sont je pense que ça
nécessite quand même peut-être pas un
entraînement dans ce cas une dextérité
que tout cas moi je n'aurais pas
incapable de tuer quatre personnes
sinon ils fassent sous les 4 mais c'est
ça quand on parle de coup de folie c'est
un coup de folie d'un mec surentraînés
quand même voilà après on sait pas à qui
quoi pourquoi mais voilà on va un peu
vite sans savoir en réalité on est dans
une espèce de machine lessiveuse
médiatique où tout le monde parle d'une
somme d'argent nation donc en fait
l'interrogation elles portent surtout
sur ses mobiles
donc il ya eu rapidement une confusion
assez généralisé sur ses mobiles puisque
certains parlaient de mobiles d'ordre
privé de dispute avec avec une collègue
de dépit amoureux ou
il ya eu aussi donc la version ce serait
quelqu'un qui se serait radicalisé pour
le moment en terme d'information ce que
l'on sait c'est que cette personne c'est
effectivement converti aller à l'islam
il ya 18 mois
et effectivement comme le disait jean
charles dans le dans le process on a
quelques éléments constitutifs d'une
préméditation puisque ces réseaux
couteau on va pas au boulot avec son cas
avec un couteau
et effectivement enfin il ya beaucoup de
questions qui se posent mais à l'heure
actuelle c'est très compliqué de pouvoir
affirmer des choses une à une en terre
la faim moi je dis aussi qu'il a eu des
bien entendu des voix en dans la nuit
mais pour le moment on ne sait pas grand
chose en plus on est sur des sujets
extrêmement inflammable donc on a on a
chacun qui essaient de il ya soit ceux
qui essaient de dire que surtout il
n'est surtout pas islamiste il ya ceux
qui disent évidemment il est trés il
s'agit donc on va essayer de la vraie
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fantasme
pas avec autour de nos peurs à travers
de commentons tout de suite à un fait
dont tous ne sait pas grand chose
c'est ça la vraie question il ya quelque
chose qui m'interpelle et ça c'est
vraiment le cas pour pour ça mais ça a
été le cas pour la faire darmanin pour
tous pour tout le reste j'ai le
sentiment qu'aujourd'hui les médias font
les procès et ça moi je trouve qu'en
terme de séparation des pouvoirs c'est
quand même quelque chose d'assez
dangereux il ya ce qu'on appelle le
secret de l'instruction il ya le temps
de la justice qui n'est pas le temps des
médias
et moi je trouve qu'il serait temps
qu'on arrête de faire le travail de la
justice qui est normalement censé nous
dire s'il ya eu préméditation ou non
c'est l'objet du procès juste je vais
donc avoir un regard un peu peut-être
corporatiste je vais défendre
d'abord les médias on peut pas dire les
médias pas essentialiser comme ça les
médias
effectivement beaucoup surtout ça sort
si vous parlez des chaînes d'information
continue effectivement on est dans cette
réalité-là médiatique aujourd'hui il ya
un événement il ya une hystérie autour
d'un événement et on en parle et on fait
venir donc des gens qui non pas
d'information mais qu'ils viennent
donner un point de vue qui n'ont langage
personne si ce n'est leur parole qui est
souvent assez peu précise donc bon
effectivement on tourne en rond
mais il ya un traitement qui est un
petit peu différent en presse écrite
s'ils sont obligés de reprendre
évidemment à des jeux regarder les
journaux lui dure de 2 vendredi ils
reprennent tous ont une laverie la
réalité médiatique c'est qu'on est dans
une sorte de course à l'échalote pour
sortir à une information que l'on n'a
pas et donc c'est là où peut intervenir
énormément dérapage effectif sans
stigmatiser les médias on peut dire que
les médias finalement sont pris dans
cette idée que de toute façon il faut se
prononcer tout de suite donc moi c'est
pas une critique sur la corporation qui
est la mienne c'est simplement que cette
société a rendu cela absolument
nécessaire avec notamment les réseaux
vous allez tous les plus grands journaux
de presse écrite qui sur l'événement
dans la minute vont être obligées de
publier quelque chose pour être
justement donc dans l'actualité donc
publie des informations quand on en a
pas on ne publie pas d'information c'est
le principe même de journée mais là où
des jeux courses dans le commentaire que
je considère que les presse
d'information qui font des commentaires
en faisant venir des gens qui ré qui
doivent commenter tout de suite ses
membres un événement ça n'a strictement
aucune valeur informative un mot pardon
jury vous parliez d'instruction
l'assassin est mort oui donc qu'est-ce
qui serait choisi ya pas de procès il
n'y a pas de je pense qu'on va quand
même y manque une enquête qui va les
dirigeants tchèques assuré marc marquez
contre lui effectivement la chose
publique c'est un comique c'est un
certain mais il y aura quand même une
enquête qui va être nommé le problème
très bien mais juge d'instruction mais
enfin ça va être vite instruit quoi
c'est pas la question de l'eau de en
fait de la culpabilité doit être une
enquête judiciaire je pense qu'il est
quand même normal plusieurs poèmes
charlène qu' on puisse en tant que
journaliste raconter ce qui s'est passé
après on va pas oui mais voilà c'est le
cas ces personnes qui sont assassinés à
coups de couteau le sont ses motivations
riz sont plus obscures mais l'événement
de toute façon est extraordinaire c'est
bien la première fois qu'on voit un je
sais pas comment il faut il qualifier
d'ailleurs c'est ce drame qu'on voit
donc pas la préfecture de police qui est
quand même un des endroits les plus
sécurisées de france donc
et en plus ça résonne avec le mal-être
policier est juste la veille policiers
qu'il 27 mai bolide donc que cela ait un
accès de fois je sais pas que ce qui
s'est réellement passé mais quand bien
même ça aurait été un accès de folie
c'était un ça pose aussi des questions
sur le management la problématique de la
médecine du travail commence
ou alors si c'est si ce type est un est
interne islamistes alors ça pousse
encore d'autres questions c'est à dire
que ils étaient les uts energy rations
pour le couvert pour le coup c'est quand
même extrêmement extrêmement
problématique donc bon pour l'instant on
peut enfin voila mon pour l'avion pour
faire des victoria
c'est quand même inquiétant parce que
alors bien sûr il ya la presse écrite
qui fait il ya des journalistes qui font
un travail exceptionnel dont tu es là
lionel vais m'essayer que la plupart des
français bon rang du travail vont
regarder les chaînes d'information
continue et vont avoir accès à ce qu'on
leur donne et ça dit quelque chose
d'aussi de notre société c'est à dire
que on est dans l'instantané on fait des
scénarios parce qu'évidemment on ne sait
rien donc on fait des hypothèses qui il
est ce si les sols etc
mais finalement dans la présentation
qu'on fait aussi de l'événement on nous
explique que ça a l'air plutôt d'être
cette histoire là en fait insidieusement
nous raconte quand même la faire comme
on imagine qu'ils allaient ils ne soient
à traverser le bourg donc ça c'est
vraiment inquiétant et je crois que
effectivement devrait enfin avoir un
système médiatique qui puisse se donner
beaucoup moins de temps ce genre
d'événement et avoir aussi une approche
un peu plus généalogie c'est à dire
avoir une approche historique des choses
il s'est passé un petit peu calé mais
justement on va perdre juste une
question à lui avoue d'ailleurs puisque
vous avez travaillé pour le cas des
dossiers notamment du cadre si vous
l'avez fait aussi jean charles donc ça
c'est plutôt du temps long du
journalisme est ce que le temps long du
jourdain ils n'étaient pas en train de
disparaître
mais de fait il a disparu c'est pas
qu'il est en train de disparaître ce
qu'il a disparu c'est l'avènement des
chaînes oui ça en lisant les médias des
zones et demi oui
donc on peut évidemment c'est un voeu
pieux de dire le temps long ok mais le
il ya des médias d'ailleurs qui se sont
constitués sur le temps long quelques
difficultés à lever leur modèle
économique dans l'intention mais la
réalité malheureusement de la presse
c'est que d'abord il ya plus de lecteurs
c'est ça la réalité la presse et puis
vous avez souvent une relation assez
schizophrène à la presse en france et
ailleurs d'ailleurs quand on fait des
études de lectorat sur ce que veut la
presse parce que valent les lecteurs ce
que valait ce que ce que veulent les
lecteurs pardon
c'est l'histoire de ce fameux rapport à
soi même cirque on s'imagine tous
souvent beaucoup plus brillant qu'on est
et dans l'est dans les dents les étude
de lectorat le lecteur veut de l'enquète
de l'analyse des papiers de fonds et
pourtant c'est ce même lecteur qui va
consommer que des médias people qui est
qui va regarder toutes les maisons les
saveurs facile d'accès les visions ou
les émissions culturelles sont à la
demande revue voilà des personnes
parquées personne ne la regarde
oui on est dans cette résidence oui je
pense qu'ils vont se faire un peu
mousser contentant d'annoncer et mijoux
lutte aurait été un peu plus passionnant
c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai que ja il
ya aussi une question de sous on répond
politiquement correctement si je faisais
pas ce qui m'amuse c'est que je subodore
là autant d'étapes que sur le sujet
suivant qui bête rouen la discours va
être va être inversé la tout le monde
dit on en parle trop et tout le monde
aime son avis et puis là sûr je
disparais de l'histoire le groupe c'est
l'éclairage
voilà donc c'est l'éclairage alors vous
voulez dire donc quelques conclure
quelque chose sur la période j'ai été
con fraternelle avec donc les
journalistes et bien maintenant je suis
roi
je trouve il n'y a pas eu de on avait
fait un prêt sommaire il y avait marqué
difficultés de l'information je trouve
qu'il ya une fuite de l'information plus
tôt et en l'occurrence je considère je
m'étonne d'avoir entendu et vu donc en
télé en radio
certains confrères qui présentait
l'absence d'information comme quelque
chose de normal or le journaliste je le
rappelle encore une fois il est là pour
rapporter de l'information donc qu'un
journaliste ne s'étonne pas que dans
cette histoire de rois on ne connaissent
pas l'origine de l'accident et qu'on ne
connaisse pas les produits et que l'on
dise à l'auditeur par exemple je pense à
ce qui a pu se dire dans certaines
radios a dit on a dit à l'auditeur
malgré les propos rassurants en gros de
ceux qui savent les ministres et le
préfet des gens s'inquiètent je trouve
que c'est une présentation de
l'information qui me paraît extrêmement
tendancieuses et grave pour un
journaliste lui seul il doit analyser
des questions et recherche de demain il
y aura lieu de s'inquiéter trouve que
c'est la liste des produits mais c'est à
dire que la première réaction
je trouve que les certains journalistes
se sont comportés un petit peu comme des
perroquets officiel oui et l'information
officielle on est revenu à des réflexes
digne de l'urss version pravda avec en
gros il ya eu un accident mais vous
inquiétez pas circulez ya rien à voir
ces tirs d'obus doigt mais il faut
qu'elle peut pas dire ça c'est de même
chose qu'aux deux tiers de ce que je
veux souligner c'est que on ne peut pas
dire il ne s'est rien passé c'est une
entreprise seveso on aurait très bien pu
dire en l'état actuel de nos
connaissances nous ne pouvons pas dire
si c'est grave ou pas encore une fois
qu'on balance cinq cent mille personnes
paniquées sur les routes en disant fuyez
fuyez la fumée est terrible on ne sait
pas ce qui se passe c'est seveso tout va
exploser donc hélas c'est la panique
généralisée dont sais pas si c'est là ce
que je dis ça tendrait à ça en grand
bain oui il ya de la fumée c'est super
grave c'est la panique on sait pas du
tout
barrez vous c'est à dire le macbook air
qui entend des discours qui reste selon
lui les gens sont assez intelligents
pour pouvoir comprendre que quand on a
une excuse d'avoir su unir entreprises
seveso classés seuil et nous on sait ce
que ça signifie que ça veut dire quoi
c'est ce que sont les il ya des tensions
la santé publique pour l'environnement
la faire on n'a pas découvert qu'une
usine seveso les gens qui habitent à
côté on sait ce que c'est qu'une usine
seveso
oui mais voilà on a l'expérience de
seveso on est en droit de se poser des
questions c'est tout à fait normal de
s'en poser tous les ans en pole il faut
avoir non mais il faut rechercher
l'information plutôt que de dire il ne
s'est rien passé je n'ai pas paniqué a
tant besoin pour avoir de portée puisque
anne charlène vous enseigneront vous
êtes à léran lionel vous êtes aussi
aller à rouen
peut-être votre témoignage
vous avez vu que maître de conférences à
l'université de rouen et donc on a nos
bureaux enfin à l'université le centre
pasteur qui est vraiment située à un
exact proximité de l'incendié
donc on a affaire déjà à des étudiants
qui sont tout à fait paniquer et qui ont
vraiment le sentiment alors là je te
rejoins un peu sur la l'ex urss même si
on en est très loin ils ont vraiment le
sentiment de vivre une forme
d'information cacher bon je pense qu en
effet le rôle de réassurance et aussi
quand même important de notre part
néanmoins alors il ne peut pas dire
qu'il n'ya rien notamment parce que bon
bah dans nos bureaux
s il ya une odeur qui est très très
présents dont qui est gênante pour les
yeux les parties respiratoires etc et on
a les fameuses galettes qui sont déposés
un petit peu partout sur nos sur nos
balcons donc on a vécu quelque chose
d'anormal d'exceptionnel et c'est vrai
qu'on peut estimer que la communication
est ici un petit peu trop verrouillée
autres au point ces petits c mais là
encore on peut peut-être aussi le mettre
sur le compte des réseaux des chaînes
d'information continue attention je ne
dis plus les médias je choisis
maintenant mais parce que c'est vrai que
je pense que le gouvernement est sous
pression et qu'on attend beaucoup de lui
alors pas dire partez sur les routes est
pas dire il n'ya rien moi je pense que
c'est le en même temps où justement et
là on aurait besoin c'est à dire de dire
en l'état actuel de nos connaissances il
est aussi de savoir si ceux ci comme par
exemple pourquoi ne moi je trouve qu'on
a tardé à nous donner la liste par
exemple des des éléments qui ont bruit
alors pour la simple et bonne raison
qu'ils avaient brûlé on là et on
pourrait peut-être tout simplement
demandé à des experts comme on sait le
faire très vite
si oui ou non il n'ya risque est que ces
experts se contredisent entre paroles
d'expert et que le gouvernement dise lui
même qui n'a pas l'expertisé pour le
savoir tout simplement si on avait
affaire à un gouvernement qui nous dit
on ne peut pas être en mesure de
connaître les dangers sur la santé
publique je pense qu'on aurait affaire à
beaucoup plus d'honnêteté sur cette
question ça a été un peu moins enfin
c'est ce que c'est ce qu'avait dit elle
a fini par le reconnaître en excusant
qu'elle ne savait pas effectivement
quand vous voyez la liste il faut être
réaliste mais moi ça me dit rien voilà
tout mais et en plus ça éviterait une
forme de jeu j'allais presque dire
d'amateurisme enfin il ya eu des
cafouillages gouvernementaux aussi
puisque des lendemains darmanin quand
même c'était s'était prononcé pour dire
que c'était grave il avait utilisé ce
terme
et quand dans le même temps le le
premier ministre oui voilà donc vous
avez retourné la porte parole du
gouvernement derrière
autonomy porte parole du gouvernement
qui a dit que le président de la
république ne s'était pas encore
transporté sur les lieux parce qu'on
attendait le résultat des études pour
savoir s'ils parient sur la santé
ces grecs effectivement en tant que que
ce week-end aussi j'étais à rouen je
suis allé au rond-point mariage à 80
kilomètres on s'inscrit encore alors on
se marie on a eu un bon parcours
oui j'en ai avec quelques uns des autres
et sur la route alors je voulais au
début j'ai pensé que je dois être un
petit peu paranoïaque j'ai senti ma
gorge déroulait donc dans la voiture on
était plusieurs banques et est donc ma
copilote et ceux à l'arrière aussi ont
eu la gorge qui pique est à 80
kilomètres avant d'ailleurs failli robot
cje pas il fallait enfin ondes
c'est un peu un total succès passés à
côté d'un superbe et gilet jaune
ils ont brûlé quatre tonnes de clochards
par week end ça vous aurait piqué la
gorge aussi peu clairs je n'en sais rien
donc justement en face de mon bureau
j'avais le rond-point des gilet jaune du
bruit et leur me et ça ne sentais pas la
même chose quand même genre mais je
t'invite à venir autour du camp bien oui
c'est quand même un tout petit peu moins
alarmantes que ce qu'on a nous quand
même à lui
merci patrice crois que c'est ça
justement qui est grave c'est à dire que
les gens qui habitent là bas
rose tente des choses sentent des choses
ont des peurs et face à cela on a l'état
qui rassure dans un premier temps est
dit on fait des analyses
donc les gens sont pas fous hier que la
peur est décuplée parce que si on fait
des analyses ça veut dire qu'on ne sait
pas et alors qu'on ne sait pas on nous
explique que finalement en l'état actuel
des choses et en l'état actuel des
connaissances il n'y a pas de problème
donc les gens ont peur juste parce que
on aimerait que l'état puisse et on peut
le comprendre aussi que l'état ne puisse
pas voir et me détendre désinformation
et qui puisse dire aux gens on n'est pas
certain de ce qui se passe
bon actuellement ça mérite pas non plus
un déplacement de toute la population en
dehors de rouen mais c'est vrai qu'une
incertitude et on comprend aussi votre
angoisse votre peur je crois que c'est
aussi le rôle de l'état que de le faire
on revient au premier sujet de la
préfecture de police dire qu'aujourd'hui
en personne n'ose dire on ne sait pas
encore
et c'est quand même ça et puis on a en a
quand même avec le recul ce qui s'était
passé pour tchernobyl ou le meuble
s'arrêter paraît-il à la frontière
franco-allemande pédicurie à côté de
l'arrêt il ya peut-être une chose à
ajouter sur justement l'habitude et
aussi on pourrait aussi essayer de se
rappeler de la canicule qui a été hier
finalement quelques semaines et là on a
un exemple un verre son mac / formation
voilà donc sur sa protection que je suis
d'accord et je pense que le gouvernement
ait finalement avec cette société de la
sécurité de la transparence où on attend
finalement que le gouvernement
s'explique sans arrêt et qu'il protège
les populations et qu'il démontre qu'il
est soucieux de la qualité de vie de
l'environnement et beaucoup de choses
dont on responsabilise encore plus je
crois en termes d'information nos
gouvernants ce qui fait que d'un côté on
a le sentiment que du coup au moindre
risque
il va y avoir une panique comme ça a été
le cas pour la canicule est là pourtant
on à l'effet inverse avec on aurait pu
attendre la même chose que pour le plan
canicule des espèces de petits chocs
d'information des kits et c est là pour
le coup on n'a rien
c'est assez paradoxal pour moi dans le
traitement de l'information
eh bien oui il n'est pas compliqué alors
voir venir un petit peu en arrière venir
l'époque de jacques chirac c'est la mort
de la chirac c'est le décryptage de
cette émission
[Musique]
donc le le décès de jacques chirac
cinquième président semble la 7ème
république
voilà qui était avec françois mitterrand
le plus longtemps au pouvoir
même si comme françois mitterrand et de
deux cohabitations non il a eu une
cohabitation limin commutation de cinq
ans il avait que la vidéo comme premier
ministre dit à sion et alors il ya ce
sondage qui moi m'a étonné mais je peux
être que deux accords de méthode et qui
place jacques chirac comme le président
préféré des français à égalité avec
charles de gaulle bien avant mitterrand
bien avant pompidou bien avant jusqu'à
sarkozy vous bien avant jusqu'à y ait 3
% fin et juste au monde qui est encore
1%
enfin voila il ressemble et on a vu la
béatification d'un président qui n'a
strictement rien fait en 12 ans dont on
a juste dit bah oui la tête de veau là
le truc sauce gribiche la bière tâter le
cul des vaches
hélas pour les français ça semble être
le lac mais du du truc c'est merveilleux
j'ai changé beaucoup de positions dire
qu'on l'a connue travailliste pour des
rares occasions syndicale de cochin en
anti européens ayant voté mastri si on
l'a connu enfin à 18 ans ou la fracture
sociale et vient dans une liaison qui
vont de l'humanité sur les marchés après
il a frayé avec l'extrême droite
après il a 6 ennemis à combattre
l'extrême droite ils étaient anti
européen est devenu pro européen
c'est juste quelqu'un qui est sûrement
sympathique très charismatique mais
politiquement géographe sympathique on
pourrait parler de tous les gens qu'il a
tués si je peux dire politiquement ça
paraît bien pour le grand public c'est
super menteur et super retraite enfin il
a trahi gillett rises car il ya très
chaban il a trahi sarko c'est mon coup
double j'ai pas je partage mais ce que
non et quel que veulent des fonds
peut-être après tout donc du fond non
non mais c'est vrai que les français ont
été touchés et but mais voilà ce que les
médias ont exagéré cette émotion c'est
aussi pour une fois on se retrouve dans
une espèce de lier passé est là à la
machine à laver médiatique mais parce
que là on la laver plus blanc que blanc
en l'occurrence il ya toujours ce
phénomène des d'historisation et que ce
sondage fait à chaud il avait été fait à
chaud pour d'autres présidents alors
mission qui jouent derrière l'émotion
qui joue évidemment mais effectivement
on peut se dire là c'est même plus les
français sont des veaux là c'est plus
digne du poisson rouge et de la mémoire
la mémoire vive qui disparaît
complètement parce que enfin parce qu'il
était on a très important dans son
dernier quinquennat notamment il était
impopulaire il a souvent été impopulaire
d'âge à marieville a été battu il y
avait inventé de 7 et 9 2 ans il a
laissé le volant est effectivement en
termes de réformes c'est le vide complet
alors après sur le plan des symboles et
de dessiner de trois choses alors oui
mais on est sûr sur des fins le symbole
ça fait partie aussi de la politique
mais effectivement sur les rivières et à
la guerre de l'irak est la guerre en
irak
il ya pour l'environnement il a fait
beaucoup quand même odieux heureusement
et il ya six coups révolte ivre quand
même c'est dire le 10 sport l'invention
des gilet jaune avec la suppression du
service militaire qui a mis la france à
feu et à sang c'est à dire que y'a plus
une seule garde mais il n'ya plus une
seule garnison dans les villes moyennes
ce qui a entraîné au delà du fait de la
suppression du service militaire
suppression des garnisons dans les
villes suppression d'une garnison dans
une ville suppression des écoles
suppression des commerces suppression
des services publics
c'est le terreau des gilet jaune alors
prêts sont audibles y'a plus rien
d'aller vite mais ça c'est
si chirac dire que ça lui a pris comme
une envie de pisser un matin en disant
bon va supprimer le service militaire
ok très bien la fille ont pas réfléchi
et voilà l'état de la famille des
réponses non mais l'état de la france
actuelle c'est lui c'est lui c'est ville
déserte qu'on traverse avec rien du tout
et sait d'où elle avait toujours dans un
territoire de mitterrand de chirac a
cessé quand même chirac qui est qui qui
est responsable de ça ce militaire quand
même en 95 si là il a tout de suite
repris dès et c'est justement pour une
solide entre 600 et c'était une bonne
décision mais ça aurait été fondée le
service militaire dans ces délais oui
parce que je trouve que d'enfin moi je
suis pas pour la prolifération nucléaire
mais je crois que à partir du moment où
bien des pays sont dotés de la bombe
nucléaire
je crois qu'il est important que qu'on
puisse effectivement d'être de tettey
non mais de pouvoir donner l'assurance
justement aussi peut on a un arsenal qui
est opérationnel nous allons pas valu
une grande popularité dans les noms mais
pour la presse donc c'est bien moi j'en
veux à jacques chirac moi c'est que
c'est pas du tout les stratégies les
jeunes gens voyageaient chat pour autre
chose et je trouve que ça na pas été
soulignée par mes confrères ou par
d'autres observateurs
j'en veux à jacques chirac
je lui en veux d'avoir dit quand il ya
eu les caricatures de mahomet ils
étaient au pouvoir les premières
caricatures parues dans charlie hebdo
il a tout de suite il a loupé
complètement le virage et en fait on lui
doit aussi il a une responsabilité
malgré tout dans ce qui s'est passé par
la suite puisque ça a été le premier à
dire il est impensable d'humilier enfin
au lieu de le défendre et de défendre
les valeurs républicaines de la france
il a dit que c'était une humiliation qui
avait été faite aux musulmans et c'est
une faute originelle c'est une faute
originelle qui en a entraîné après bien
d'autres
je pense qu'un alors ce qui peut
expliquer chirac
on n'a pas beaucoup dit c'est dire que
je pense qu'il a il a été secrétaire
d'état en 68 négociant les accords de
grenelle allons rencontrer les syndicats
souvient cet épisode il était armé il
avait un pistolet et je crois qu'elle a
gardé de sa l'idée que la
la france était une société saman
fragile et que le moindre la moindre
réforme brutale risque et de la mettre à
feu et à sang je crois que c'est ce qui
explique un peu mais le fait qu'il n'ait
pas fait grand chose
ils avaient peur de que ça explose oui
il ya des histoires et il sait pas et
c'est peut-être pas fou il n'est
peut-être pas une analyse totalement
sauf quand on voit la difficulté de
réformer ce pays comment on peut pas ne
rien faire et ils étaient quand même
vous a fait une autre explication est
tout à fait intéressante mais on élit un
président quand même pour qu'ils
dépassent justement c'était en ligue i
aussi pour qu ils unissent les gens
c'est de la situation de la france
actuelle on lui doit la lui sur la rue
laurier à faire de l'argent en
l'occurrence enfin l'histoire des
caricatures à cette époque là c'était
surtout blessé
c'est un vrai soutien mais moi je pense
pas que ça l'idée ça du tout à l'époque
à l'époque c'était pas du tout ça ça
c'était le vernis la réalité c'était
surtout qu'on vendait enfin oui qu'on en
vend toujours c'est en fait il fallait
pas froisser nos amis acheteurs
acheteurs de ailleurs tenir très proche
d'eux avec saddam hussein un des potes
mais on était sûr c'est des choses les
valeurs républicaines ont sacrifié sur
l'autel de la realpolitik
parce que ce que n'a pas fait sarkozy
s'est refusé pour une position tout à
fait inverse défendre jaffer marca
sarkozy françois hollande c'est un
certain style de présidence alors qu'il
met rien fait ou qu'il ait fait quelque
chose à mon sens on s'en prend la
mauvaise personne parce que je moi je
en tant que concessionnaire je ne suis
franchement pas convaincu que ce soit au
président de la république d'être
présent h 24 partout sur tous les sujets
parce que c'est ces premiers ministres
qui sont responsables de leurs actions
ou leur inaction le banc pendant cinq
ans il n'a pas gouverné
de son premier septennat il ya cinq ans
de cohabitation c'est justin qui prévaut
ministre mais justement luminosité de
dissolution cela dit absolument
caustique mais justement le fait de
pouvoir être un président qu'il fallait
être élue sur la vie oui c'est
systématique en matière de cohabitation
s'est toujours impliqué sur la scène qui
règne en l'occurrence je pense pas qu'il
ait pu calculer ce faisant il espère
également c'est que du coup il était en
forme en prenant beaucoup maintenant la
low life essayer d'être justement un
petit peu moins sur le devant de la
scène - dans la vie perte consommation
et je pense que finalement c'est par
rapport à cette nouvelle société qui
essaye d'être un petit peu plus dans
dans quelque chose de plus qui attend
peut-être de ses acteurs un peu moins
d'investissements et jacques chirac
incarner très bien cette idée d'un
président qui était là pour inaugurer
les chrysanthèmes comme le disait le
général de gaulle c'est à dire
simplement excellent retour
alors moi j'ai le sentiment que lui a
incarné vraiment complètement cela c'est
à dire ces présidents de la république
étaient là simplement pour la fonction
honorifique c'était la reine
d'angleterre jacques chirac et et
peut-être que ce colloque que ses pleurs
avec lui c'est cette figure
présidentielle qui était incarnée à la
fois par une forme d'idéologie
républicaine avec cette idée de
quelqu'un qui soit là quand même pour
les poulets grand moment c'est ce qu'il
a fait aussi avec la guerre en irak
c'est à dire qu'il soit là à l'étranger
mais pas nécessairement dans la
politique intérieure et est ce que ça ne
vaut pas le coup de re réfléchir à cette
succession du président est assez
intéressant c'est alors par exemple
quant au livre le livre de bruno le
maire qui était directeur de cabinet de
villepin à l'époque était prévu nice
c'est très étonnant parce que c'est vrai
que à la fois à chaque chaque fois qu'il
veut une réforme
il disait en gros écoutez du haut de mon
incompétence qui est grande
moi si j'étais vous je ferai pas
mais il laissait faire en même temps y
laisser faire le premier ministre c'est
assez c'est une des lectures en effet
assez dans la lettre de la de la
constitution en effet et puis c'est vrai
que là aussi sur l'inaction je pense que
ça n'est pas nécessairement une posture
qui était la sienne mais qui était celle
aussi des gouvernements d'avant c'est à
dire qu'on a maintenant l'habitude aussi
d'un rythme politique est complètement
différent alors en effet il n'a pas fait
grand chose par rapport à notamment
mitterrand qui lui et qui était avant
lui mais il y avait aussi un autre style
les présidents imprimé leur marque
plutôt sur des grands caps mais pas sur
des réformes de société sur la
dérégulation et les services publics
j'ajouterai que ça n'est pas vraiment
lui qui était aux manettes puisque ce
sont des directives de dérégulation qui
nous ont été imposées par l'union
européenne donc je suis pas sûr qu'on
puisse lui mettre tous les maux de la
société je suis ravi qu'on ferait de
grandes réformes de société jeux
mitterrand a fait des grandes réformes
de mort il ya les ai assez je vous
suivez sur l'idée de reine d'angleterre
oui peut-être mais je pense qu'ils
sortent quand je vois que giscard et 3%
se trouve qu'il ne sorte d'injustice sur
cet état de jyske amis quand même
l'interruption de grossesse le vote à 18
ans j'aurais plaisir
il y avait des vaches ont coûté
d'ailleurs je crois que cela dit quelque
chose de notre pays c'est à dire que les
français ont tu parlais tout à l'heure
de symbolique en politique je crois que
c'est encore plus vrai en france c'est à
dire qu'il ya une fascination pour
pouvoir et on a une détestation du roi
lui coupe la tête et dans le même temps
il ya une admiration pour lui si elles
sont avancées c'est quand même très bon
marché c'est cette voie là ces décès
parce que la vème république a aussi été
construite comme ça justement parce que
la vème république est un résultat
extraordinaire de long régime de
républicains c'est comme la vème
république du 4 avant et qui nous a
permis d'arriver à un subtil équilibre
où on a un président qui est comme un
roi
ouais mais sans l'être complètement
totalement mais plus allen disait très
justement qu'effectivement le président
république doit rester dans les grandes
lignes dans une sorte de magistrature
morale doit s'occuper des affaires
extérieures doit impulser des idées
générales est ensuite laissée aux
ministres à paupières d'exercice de
démission alors laissant la direction
je crois qu'effectivement de ce point de
vue là jacques chirac a très très bien
fait les choses et c'est aussi cela qui
manque
même si sur le fond je ne suis pas de
ceux qui vont dire qu'effectivement il a
un bilan extraordinaire
il est beaucoup d'hommages qui ont été
rendues évidemment ajaccio proposant de
regarder un qui est assez singulier
cette fille du marquis de breteuil qui
il a connu quelques de chirac à sion ce
pauvre qui était son délai vous même à
sciences po
vous savez on s'inscrit à sciences po en
première année et puis comme j'étais
parti aux états unis
je suis arrivé in extremis là dessus on
m'a dit reste une un maître de
conférences tous les autres son prix est
plus qu'honnête où il s'appelle chirac
alors moi j'ai dit bon ben je prends
chirac
j'ai pas le choix de toute façon
j'aimerais et c'est vrai que je jacques
chirac m'a beaucoup frappé il a été mon
maître de conférences à sciences po et
c'est quelqu'un qui
qui sûrement et beaucoup d' influence
sur moi j'ai souvent que c'est un peu
comme à comme un maître aimé des choses
amusantes avec chirac c'est que quand il
y avait un étudiant qui posait une
question un petit peu comme on dit un
petit peu je dirai pas si dieuze j'en
fais un petit peu un petit peu précise
un petit peu assommante
or chirac gérer cette phrase
extraordinaire passons sur les détails
et remettez à sa place les étudiants qui
avaient voulu les critiques acerbes
on s'attendait à ce qu'il se passe
quelque chose comme ça c'était pas
quelqu'un de deux légers voilà il était
très très très costaud
julie témoignage visant à mieux penser
que vous aviez passé le témoignage
absolument hallucinant d'anne hidalgo
alors parce que la wii pour vos
étudiants qui doit avoir entre 20 et 24
ans alors eux ils écoutent un hidalgo il
dit anne hidalgo était l'adjoint de
jacques chirac à la mairie de paris
elle faisait partie de son staff
politiques le disent les eaux étaient
met à tomber par terre oui c'est le
meilleur maire de paris il restera le
plus grand mais alors quand c'est enfin
c'était le commerce couvert de l'ère
moderne comment est ce que rené pareil
quand on s'appelait nidal vous mais
est-ce que vous sauve débit concert de
discours de chirac à la mort de
mitterrand était habituellement apprécié
enfin étonnant même y avait des bombes
des gens qui s'étaient combattus quand
même politiquement tribunaux car il n'a
heureusement de respect où il y avait
une hauteur de vue de chirac à ce moment
là sur le décès de mitterrand où il n'a
pas essayé nous faire croire qu'il était
d'accord
il était respectueux de l'ancien
président et c'était très bien alors que
la hidalgo étaient pas dans le respect
elle était dans l' espèce de
d'accaparement du d'une d'une statue qui
avait l'air de cas l'air de plaire à
tout le monde en un matin il serait qui
perd chirac c'est bon pendant six mois
quoi aussi c'est qu'on est quand même
dans les premiers instants et que
là aussi je vais finalement devenir
temps du deuil
oui voilà il ya entendu d'oeil à un
tendre moment je suis et on n'est pas là
pour faire sa critique on l'a fait quand
il était au pouvoir il a été très
décriée il sait qu'on il a combattu ses
opposants laissons aussi l'apaisement
des mémoires faire affaire mais on est
là pouvoir interroger la réalité et en
l'occurrence chirac était à était devenu
très populaire une fois qu'il n'était
plus en charge des affaires n'est plus à
faire comme souvent et puis après on
oublie et ce qui fascine avec chirac
s'était augmenté vous avez voir
l'enterrement de giscard que je souhaite
le plus loin possible
non mais c'est la personnalité que c'est
de la personnalité de chirac qui était
fascinante et détonnant dans le monde
politique
c'est quelqu'un de chaleureux bien peu
d'hommes politiques chaleureux qui
paraît proche des français qui leur
ressent qui ressemble aux français donc
c'est ça qui plaisait mais ça ne fait
pas effectivement un homme peut alors se
produit nous qui avait lancé jacques
chirac en politique et jacques chirac a
lancé aussi un certain nombre d'hommes
politiques dans la carrière politique
c'est le cas de pierre bédier
du coup d'éclat président du conseil
général des yvelines qui rend hommage à
jacques chirac aussi engagé gemeng
anecdote plutôt membres son énergie sa
gentillesse fourchette
il aimait bien rigoler tout en étant
quelqu'un très sérieux quelqu'un
d'immense pas simplement ce qu'ils
étaient présents partie parce que
c'était personnalité rayonnante
c'est vrai que c'est le seul président
il y aura peut-être y aura peut-être
sarkozy puisqu'il est maintenant
il devrait passer en correctionnelle
mais c'est le seul président qui était
qu'on a donné quand même à deux ans de
prison avec sursis
c'est là aussi c'est un tournant c'est
un tournant de la république la georges
pompidou et françois mitterrand son pdg
général de gaulle également sont morts
peu après donc ça vient pas assez de
temps et de gauche n'a pas laissé le
temps à des condamnations peut-être pas
de gaulle mais c'est vrai qu'en tant sur
les comptes de campagne ou autre je suis
pas sûr qu'ils soient tous complètement
exonérés de
de petit grief ou de grands 1 c'est vrai
qu'on entendait roland dumas dira
d'ailleurs on n'a pas osé reprendre
leurs comptes de campagne c'était donc
c'est vrai que emmanuel macron humaine
d'ailleurs est pas complètement certain
d'être tranquille sur cette question
parce qu'il ya des ja parquet financier
qui s'était saisie d'une affaire dont on
n'a plus jamais entendu parler mais qui
est quand même encore en cours ou à
gérer l'exceptionnel manger non je pars
je parle pas du tout pour la
condamnation de jacques chirac mais on
peut pas vraiment dire que c'est le seul
ou en tout cas il y en aura sûrement
d'autres et les autres étaient morts
avant donc çà çà çà çà resituer un petit
peu dans le paysage
mais dans les faits cette seule seule
cgt a parlé avec le cas de nicolas
sarkozy je pense avec la belge c'est
parce que c'est raconter d'où pas non il
va pas se rompre
pas forcément sur la condamnation mais
c'est vrai qu'en tout cas sur toutes les
poursuites y en a sûrement qui l'instant
laissons faire la justice en effet
ajouté on a parlé de temps du deuil tout
à l'heure et c'est vrai que quand j ai
moi même allumé ma télé peu de temps
après l annonce de sa mort et même le
lendemain quand je regarde et je
trouvais dommage qu'on insiste à ce
point là sur sa condamnation
et oui qui ont d'abord on a beaucoup
aussi parlé de ses infidélités
on a parlé de sang qui n'épouse
difficultés et c'était pour allaiter
terrain je trouvais que c'était quand
même plutôt plutôt indigne ses
infidélités c'est pour beaucoup dans sa
popularité
parce qu'en france c'est merveilleux
mais un président qui comme ça a porté
sur la la gente féminine je veux dire
pour tout le monde dans les pistes rose
il est bon notre président
sinon c'est mort car c est de la
présenter
présenté comme ça ça n'aurait pas dû
accepter totalement oui c'est vrai que
ça va faire peur des foules l'auto peut
se passer
non quand donc on n'est pas obligé de
souliers à la mort de quelqu'un on aime
bien les jets de vous une maîtresse veut
dire ça fait la rue michel on est à une
époque on va passer à la polémique avec
les propos d'eric zemmour
c'est la polémique alors évidemment mais
c'est un discours qui fait beaucoup de
bruit que celui d'eric zemmour à la
convention de la droite de marion
maréchal bars et salons vip le pen ont
marqué le pen je suis passé la petite
île alors appelant eczéma ou une batte
contre une armée d'occupation dans
l'uniforme serait la djellaba pour moi
c'est violent c'est plus loin à la suite
et pierre quelqu'un veut prendre à laver
sur sur eric zemmour je je je trouve
qu'ils réalisent l'exploit politiquement
de se retrouver à la droite de marion
maréchal-le pen ce qui est quand même
assez sidérant puisque on avait rarement
entendu des propos aussi aussi
je me demande d'ailleurs si on va voir
si vraiment le coup de la loi
des poursuites pour incitation à la
haine raciale et je n'avais jamais
entendu ça même delà de la bouche d'un
politique d'extrême droite donc il est
allé encore plus loin
donc en réalité c'est pas un politique
mais je pense qu'il faut que ce soit
aujourd'hui en politique puisqu'il là il
rentre clairement dans la politique et
il doit être traité comme tel je pense
donc moi je suis complètement contre
l'interdiction de enfin le censurer mais
en l'occurrence en l'occurrence je
trouve que de fait il devrait il va être
censuré logiquement puisque il sort de
saclay il sort de son rôle de
journaliste aujourd'hui les plus
journaliste et essayiste il est il est
facile politique c'est de mieux à
politique oui et donc il a un propos qui
est éminemment politique
c'est renaud camus par exemple qui parle
de grand remplacement c'est pas c'est
pas un politique c'est un écrit mme je
pense que ces petits est-ce qu'on a une
position conserver notre en l'occurrence
dans le changement
r je crois même savoir que le front
national lui avait proposé d air qui l'a
longuement hésiter qu'il a refusé on va
pas parler des raisons pour lesquelles
il a refusé mes roues
un jeu il a peut-être compris
malheureusement que quelqu'un de la
société civile pouvait incarner
aujourd'hui une force politique et lui
il va s'inscrire là dedans
donc moi je me défonce et même s'il est
poussé à ça alors un haut fond les
propos et de lui éminemment politique et
il se positionne clairement
politiquement donc il doit être traité
en politique et je considère que les
journalistes du figaro d'ailleurs qui
refusent un pardon entre traitant
politique vous traitez on essayiste par
exemple non mais là il est les gens là
là il s'inscrit il s'inscrit dans un
discours politique et dans une formation
politique clairement avec des affinités
avec avec dans un courant et d'ailleurs
je pense kil soo présentera assez
rapidement mais il a un rôle il est il a
un rôle politique pour moi un
journaliste ne doit pas être aussi
partisan il est passé à autre chose
donc il doit être pas ses clients leader
ce qui est important c'est ses propos ou
pas ces propos après qu'il ait une
casquette de journaliste d'essayer sous
forme ans les nantais l'expression sa
cotation la haine ce qu'il ya des lois
il tombe dans les bras son propos il est
politique doit être consigné doit avoir
dangereux de catégoriser à ce point là
ça voudrait dire que du coup on ne peut
plus avoir de point de vue oui si on
n'est pas justement historique ce qui
était d'ailleurs toujours son point de
vue c'était de lui lui seul sait
peut-être historique d'être reconnu
comme historien mais je pense qu'au
contraire ils essayent de développer ce
qui est à mon sens d'ailleurs encore
plus dangereux une forme d'idéologie qui
se détache de la politique mais qui soit
un peu comme le malraux de gaulle c'est
à dire une pensée sauf qu'il n'est pas
une pensée politique pas sûr là il est
pas sur la littérature sur l'histoire y
est éminemment politique je sais d'un
métier il était un point c'est à dire
que il est il reprend le programme
empire du front national dit mais ça
n'est pas de la politique c'est un point
de vue je pense vraiment que c'est
distincts on regarde la loi de fait
c'est un acteur politique selon m
c'est ainsi que je trouve ça mais la
politique a le droit de tout dire alors
qu un essayiste n'a pas le droit non il
va filer droit de dire ce qu'il veut
dire
mais il faut il faut savoir d'où il
parle c'est tout ce que je trouve ce que
je trouve enfin dans ce que vous dites
ce que je retiens moi c'est qu'au fond
ses propos le plus cosy et messieurs
c'est parce que vous dites vous même
nous corriger ses propos le plus à
s'engager politiquement c'est à dire que
au fond et ses propos vous faut en faire
un candidat à la présidentielle ou rein
ou en tout cas et le pousser à se
présenter à se présenter comme avoir un
courant d'idées derrière lui et à se
présenter peut-être aux prochaines
présidentielles prêtées à des élections
c'est ça quand il est sorti des skis
complètement de son rôle de deux pôles
et ces mêmes pays les mêmes pull en
laine dans la presse que contre cerveau
est ce que par hasard c'est bon ça vole
en plus pour ce début mai quoi sert de
ça et je trouve que justement tu parlais
des qualifications les gars je trouve ça
sera encore plus dangereux de considérer
qu'il est en politique et c'est un
acteur politique puisque dans ce cadre
là les débats sont généralement beaucoup
plus j'y fais par exemple tous nos juges
sont beaucoup plus souples sur
l'appréciation des des discours
politiques ou autres alors qu en tant qu
un influenceur ça fait penser un peu à
caroline receveur dont je vais pas
forcément utiliser ce terme là mais en
tant qu' en tant qu est saisissant tant
qu'idéologue
laplaud c'est à dire que on a le droit à
des idéologies mais pas à des idéologies
extrêmes en france et donc moi moi je
crois bien plus qu'ils gagneraient à
être catégorisés comme quelqu'un qui
veut influencer les idées donc quelqu'un
qui propose même une certaine vision de
la france que les politiques devraient
adopter ou non mais je crois pas qu'on
constitue dans le personnel politique en
quoi je crois pas qu'on gagnerait en
termes je vais parce que je veux le fond
mais je me contrefous un peu de savoir
si les séismes de la nature de d'eric
zemmour me voilà sur ce qu'il dit ce qui
est excessif bien évidemment est de
toute façon stupide etc mais il faudrait
pas résumer les propos de zemmour à ce
qu'ils ont d'excessif justement parce
que c'est quand même sur un sujet qui
est un sujet important
un sujet qui contrairement à ce que
toute une classe politique essaie de
mettre un torchon là dessus mais c'est
quand même un truc important
l'immigration et l'islam et donc moi je
ne partage pas les idées d'eric zemmour
mais ce trou quand même totalement
normal qu'on ait le droit d'avoir peur
de l'islam le droit d'exprimer une
pensée qu'après ces propos soient
haineux et qu'il exagérait c'est une
certitude il ya même un débat là-dessus
mais on a quand même le droit france
espère de dire me dit cela ne vous fait
peur que l'islam fait peur et que ça
pose des questions on a quand même le
droit de dire que y'a bien probablement
quelques quelques craintes avant etc
c'est un avis et une opinion on est en
france on a le droit de le dire et là on
est en train de mettre une sorte de
chape de plomb doit justement c'est la
cinquième fois jeunes au problème de la
liberté d'expression mais on a le la
ligue
la liberté d'expression c'est une
histoire de courage individuel
finalement on a toujours le droit de
tout dire la seule limite c'est la loi
c'est la loi la citation beau et le cbc
parce qu'on attaque surtout sur lui sur
le thème ce qui il aurait tenu un autre
digne d'un discours aussi excessifs sur
une partie de la population - moins
sujette à polémique là on n'aurait
probablement rien yeux d'ali bongo c'est
pas très grand mais là sur l'islam c'est
une sorte de chasse gardée aulas
attention il a parlé disent donc
l'éducation qu'on parle de l'islam on
est disqualifié on n'a pas le temps si
on tient compte youtube on voit un
ostracisme donc cissé qui caressent les
matrix non c'était pas vrai parce que
justement on parle depuis tout à l'heure
de l'application de la loi les juges
sont très scrupuleux sur cette question
pour ne pas faire justement de l'islam
une forme de chasse gardée sur laquelle
n'aurait pas le droit de s'exprimer
michel houellebecq a eu l'audace
d'annoncer dans une de ses interviews je
crois que l'islam était une religion la
plus con du monde l'agent de choses là
et pour le coup le tribunal juste avant
la publication juste avant la
publication plate forme et de son roman
bien plus polémiques ensuite ce sera
mission après ce qui pour le coup là
aussi est passée sans qui aucun problème
et il a été relaxé parce que justement
c'est ses sorties du domaine de la
polémique etc je crois qu'on a une
distinction à faire entre le propos sur
les religions qui évidemment doit être
libre et le propos est là dessus la
jurisprudence de la cour européenne et
doit nommer très bien conçu c'est à dire
qu'on peut s'exprimer sur les religions
mais tout dépend du ton qu'on utilise
dès lors qu' il y a une volonté à
l'excès ou à la polémique et à la
vexation
dans ce cadre là il ya une censure et
moi je crois que à partir du moment où
eric zemmour commence à assimiler
l'islam sans parler même du jihadisme 2
ou de l'islam radical
mais à partir du moment où ils
assimilent une religion au nazisme
et oui donc il fait un parallèle même
historique qu'il essaye de fonder entre
ces deux mouvements politiques
là il est dans quelque chose qui est
gros rythme en est juridiquement mais on
ne peut pas accepter dire et le dévie
tout à leur reprocher chirac ne pas
avoir défendu des caricaturistes
est ce que au fond c'est on n'est pas
dans le même bain mêmes propos steyer
qu'est-ce qu'on n'a pas le droit de tout
dire aussi on a le droit de se
caricaturer
le droit de dire non pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi forcément évoqué demazis mme
pourquoi aller dans cet excellent centre
ya forcément d'autres caricatures et
avec des séquences d'une religion est
une communauté qui est qu'ils estiment
qu'ils avaient commis de théorie la loi
en fait quelque part les limites qui ont
été construites autour la liberté
d'expression ont été faites de manière à
ce que justement la liberté d'expression
soit maintenue d'une certaine manière ce
qui tombe sous le coup de la loi c'est
l'interdiction d'un site est aussi
l'interdiction d'inciter au meurtre à la
haine et donc la haine engendre
justement des destructions est donc une
impossibilité pour les personnes qui de
paris est atteinte et justement zemmour
connaît très bien ces questions parce
qu'il a l'habitude de ces propos
polémiques et il est très intelligent
dans son propos puisqu'il a des propos
extrêmes il parle de l'armée il parle de
mai et en même temps ils n'incitent pas
directement 10 en premier les armes ou
battez-vous etc et c'est là qu'il est
dangereux justement parce que quelque
part il peut ensuite tout à fait se
drape et enfin ceux se retrancher
liberté d'expression pour dire justement
que ce qu'il a dit ne tombent pas sous
le coup de la loi comme la liberté
d'expression est extrêmement protégé en
france
et en europe plus généralement c'est
même le droit fondamental le plus
protégé dans la jurisprudence moi quand
j'ai fait ma tête je me suis aperçu le
conseil constitutionnel protéger
excessivement la liberté d'expression
quitte à aller un peu trop loin mais
parce que c'est la liberté qui permet de
garantir la démocratie et donc sa chance
là effectivement ça peut susciter un
certain nombre de dérives
à partir du moment où on a des personnes
qui intelligemment vont essayer de jouer
entre les mots pour essayer de glisser
et de passer à travers la jurisprudence
justice pour effectivement dire ce qui
est ce qui est le droit est ce qui ne
l'est pas et c
je me suis beaucoup plus inquiet sur le
tribunal populaire qui a lieu en ce
moment enfin qui se réunit tous les
jours et qui décide
parce que c'est un peu mince trimer
donne dans les radios des valeurs ça hop
lors par exemple zemmour au nom de la
liberté d'expression qu'on lui refuse à
lui
sur france inter et 100% du temps
traiter de fumier de d'ordures et
la langue avec demande de fumier c'est
normal quand c'est un mec de qui pensent
pas comme vous mais lui n'a pas loin
dans le sens de la liberté d'expression
que tout journaliste demande son
exclusion de médias c'est un scandale
c'est le boulot des journalistes alors
l'occurrence je trouve que oui parce que
pour moi il vous en pensiez qu'il est
sorti de son canal et les plus grands
analystes c'est terminé c'est autre
chose il est passé à autre chose
donc oui je trouve que c'est normal
quand on compte puis les journalistes
sont garants de la ligne éditoriale de
leur journal dont qui sont totalement
endroit ils sont dans leur rôle en
s'opposant par exemple on est tout à
fait dans le rôle du journaliste oui
mais qui d'ailleurs plus mesuré
puisqu'ils ont dit qu'en tant qu'invité
pour proposer son oui il pourrait être
celui c'est en quelque sorte il
participe plus mais sur la liberté
d'expression j'aimerais juste dire une
chose c'est que on est en moi je pense
qu'on a tout à fait on a toujours le
droit de tout dire à partir du moment
avec les limites légales que ça c'est
juste une histoire de courage
d'ailleurs charlie hebdo le montre à peu
près toutes les semaines ils ont le
courage de publier à peu près tout ce
qu'ils veulent c'est une histoire de
courage individuel mais là où on peut
être très inquiet pour les libertés
pour les libertés d'expression notamment
c'est que il ya eu une loi qui a été
votée au mois de juillet dernier qui
s'appelle la loi avia dans lequel le
gouvernement pour lutter contre les
propos haineux et on sera tous d'accord
évidemment pour lutter contre des propos
haineux sur internet se dessaisit deux
de ses attributs de puissance publique à
savoir du juge il squeeze le juge pour
donner aux gaffes à à savoir google et
facebook
c'est eux qui vont décider demain ce qui
sera un propos haineux ou ne sera pas
approprié est ce qui est exprimé à
responsabiliser aussi on n'a plus le
temps malheureusement mais c'est parce
que c'est un vrai c'est un vrai les
abandonne on va là il ya deux choses de
doses avant autres provinces débat on
n'a pas parlé de jeff koons sont un peu
le temps donnera le ton donné leur part
les deux bouquets de tulipes et puis
vous nous dire une bonne raison de lire
jackpot c'est politiquement très
incorrect heures sera peut-être pas
plaire à tous table mais c'est des
libertés d'expression mal à rester
debout dit non mais c'est un très très
bon roman
voilà prof de philo une qui fait une
fable politique ou sociale
irrévérencieuse et politiquement très
incorrect on est au delà de houellebecq
donc mais c'est un peu mieux écrit merci
infiniment
lionel débit merci beaucoup jean
baptiste du care and billing et
jean-charles la jolie a très vite pour
un nouveau prof
[Musique]